why and lawmakers are considering a ban
on some popular sunscreen to protect
coral reefs research has found that a UV
filtering ingredient commonly found in
lotions harms the coral up to fourteen
thousand tons of sunscreen wound up in
coral reef areas of the ocean every year
scientists say it contributes to the
ecosystem damage Carter Evans got a
first-hand look at the problem near Kona
Hawaii from both the ocean and the air
the Big Island of Hawaii pristine
coastline is home to one of the state's
largest coral reefs a miles long stretch
that scientists say is dying at an
alarming rate paradise helicopters took
us up for a bird's-eye view
[Laughter]
ecologist dr. Greg Asner has studied the
reefs for more than 25 years in a plane
outfitted with special imaging sensors
he can determine the health of the coral
by its color
the red all over the map is dead or
dying coral it charms in there and to
see how bad it really is we have to go
underwater this is now a dead zone we
see the corals that died a few years ago
those are the skeletons that are kind of
eroded now and then you see the corals
that died recently they're still
standing up but they're dead there's no
pigment they're just ghosts and it's not
just happening in Hawaii coral reefs are
dying off around the world scientists
say it's mostly due to rising ocean
temperatures but new evidence suggests
certain types of sunscreens are making
it even worse in popular tourist areas
here we have a number of tests going on
biologist dr. Robert Richmond and his
team studied the effects of an active
ingredient common in sunscreens called
oxybenzone you're talking about like a
shot glass in a swimming pool these are
the kinds of levels where things begin
have action his research confirms even a
trace amount of oxybenzone is toxic to
coral first thing they give up are
things like reproduction and growth and
then he will eventually die this drug
scientific evidence is what encouraged
Hawaii lawmakers to propose a statewide
ban on the sale of all sunscreens that
contain oxybenzone state senator will
espero says people will have to learn to
use sun blocks that contain titanium and
zinc instead if Hawaii does approve this
ban it'll be the first state to do so
yes I'd like to see Hawaii take the lead
and make certain that we can do all we
can to protect our ocean environment but
sunscreen makers are fighting back a
group representing about 90% of the
cosmetic and personal care products
industry says there is no conclusive
scientific evidence that sunscreen
ingredients negatively impact coral
reefs at levels that have been detected
in tourist areas dr. Richmond disagrees
the levels that were finding in the
water are the levels at which it's
having that biological impact what can
we do to slow down what's happening at
this point it's real tough to think
about ways to slow
ocean warming but locally we can do a
lot to take stress off the reef so
sunscreen might be a good place to start
it's one that we can all contribute to
for CBS this morning Carter Evans Kona
Hawaii really interesting story what are
we doing to the planet yeah just use
sunblock y'all yes I'm back all right